I said yesterday that I was going to say
a bit more of
because I think especially on the topic
freewill it's very important to get
clear about what the difference is
between them and they're both perfectly
real let me just remind you a few things
that are in the manifest image colors
the colors are part of our manifest
image unless we're colorblind
living things and agents opportunities
there are opportunities in the manifest
image that's one of the things that we
recognize free will dollars
there's dollars currently good things
scientific image has proteins and atoms
and quarks and mania strings you know
we'll we'll get around to that and so
here's a whole bunch of different things
and they're obviously very different
opportunities and dollars are not very
much like atoms and quarks and they all
as Steve was saying yesterday they're
all real in some sense but maybe there
are different senses and the question of
how to negotiate back and forth between
the two images is the problem that
Summers recommends to philosophers that
I think he's right and I take myself to
be involved and helping people see how
to get back and forth between these two
images and freewill is one of the most
important ones but there's two
approaches let's go let's go back for a
well no sir
there's the hard-nosed approaching the
diplomatic approach the hard-nosed
approach says from the scientist X
doesn't is it's just an illusion it
doesn't exist
cars don't exist the alternative is
exist but it's quite different from what
tradition supposes now look at a few
cases and decide for yourself how you
would go on these time does it exist
[Music]
but it isn't quite what people think of
this right it may or may not be but it
certainly exists yeah causation even
though even though atoms even though
fermions and bosons aren't coloring
how about dollars they exist you're us
yeah okay so it seems that people here
aren't very hard-nosed about this they
tend to take the opposite but when it
comes to free will
well the mad dog naturalist might take
the part well is Dean but when it comes
to free will what I've discovered in the
last years is there's a veritable army a
veritable chorus of distinguished
neuroscientists and other scientists
that say take the hard nosed approach to
this they say free will doesn't exist
it's an illusion and I think they're
making some huge mistakes and I want to
just outline briefly well why do they
think so well let's look at look at look
at Dilbert for me he's this is a this
epitomizes the freewill issue I think
the chemistry the brain controls what
people do with cars and how can we blame
people for their actions as people I
free will to do as they choose are you
saying that free will is not part of the
permanent of course it is but it's the
part of the brain that's out there just
being kind of free love the hand waving
so you're saying the freewheel part of
the brain is exempt from the natural
laws of science business obviously
otherwise we couldn't blame people or
anything
you think the free will part of the
brain is attached or does it just float
in your body oh is the shot all right
now I think that actually captures the
quandary of the freewill problem really
very well we have all that all the
elements that give people a problem and
here's my tentative diagnosis of what
these neuro scientists doing
they may argue these ideas seem to be
incoherent right so free will must be an
illusion and I want to show who's a
problem with this
I think free will is as real as colors
and Israel's dollars but it's not quite
what you think they're any more than
colors and dollars are what you think
they are so in order to get clear about
what freewill is you have to get abandon
some of the ancient mythology which is
indeed incoherent here's here's Tom
Wolf's a canny observer of the of the
social scene great phrase of his the
conclusion people out beyond the
laboratory walls are drawing is the fix
is in we're all hardwired that and don't
blame me I'm wired wrong I think he's
exactly right that's the conclusion that
is out beyond the laboratory walls but I
want to challenge it and say look oh
alright let my left out us live I guess
wired wrong okay what would it be to be
wired right is there any way that you
could be wired right and have free will
and have responsibility that's really
what the issue is and I'm gonna claim
that nothing we have learned in
neuroscience nothing we've learned in
naturalism shows that we can't be wired
right for free will but you have to
understand something a little bit
different by freewill from what
tradition would say everybody knows how
to play rock paper and scissors
what's the best strategy Renda - but
we're lousy randomizers so here's a good
strategy if you really were gonna play
this for money go to a table of random
numbers copy down 100 memorize it or
write it down on a piece of paper
consult then go you can't do better than
that as long as you keep the piece of
paper secret now this idea of keeping
your choices having having a poker face
and keeping your choices hidden is I
think deeply appreciated and is
essential to the manifest image but
what's happened is that philosophers for
several thousands of years thousand
years have thought it's not enough just
to sort of keep your choices hidden
they've got to be completely hidden
they've got to be hidden absolutely so
you want to be somewhat unpredictable
and this has been inflated by
philosophers for thousands of years into
absolute unpredictability
why because philosophers always inflate
to absolutes when they can it just makes
life easy here's Jerry Fodor for
instance one wants to be what tradition
has it that Eve was when she bit the
Apple perfectly free to do otherwise so
perfectly free in fact that even God
couldn't tell which way she'd jump
perfect expression of this inflated idea
well why does one want that another
words one wants a miracle you can't have
it and you don't need it all you need is
to be unpredictable to the agents that
you actually encounter so let me let me
sum up as a sort of challenge if you
think that in determinism is required
for free will I think you're wrong with
one exception and one exception only if
you anticipate the future in which you
think you are going to be playing rock
paper and scissors for big stakes with
God then you better hope for quantum
indeterminacy
to play a role otherwise it doesn't
matter a deterministic world is exactly
as good as an indeterminate ik world you
would have just as much free will in the
deterministic world as in an
undetermined world as long as you keep
your list to yourself here's my here's
my hypothesis that human beings for
thousands of years
have appreciated the value of a poker
face they have felt threatened whenever
they see somebody who seems to be able
to anticipate their decision me if
you've ever had a magician force a card
on you
III hang around with hired magicians
someone a friend of mine once did
something he would never do in public
very good card magician he said here
pick a card any card and he enforced the
the ten of diamonds on me
I picked the time of diamonds and
limited bathroom shuffled the deck just
pick a card again ten of diamonds
shuffle the deck pick a card to get the
ten of Dimes he forced the ten of
diamonds only about ten times in a row
and I was taking it from the bottom of
the day I was you know I was doing
everything I could think of and every
time he anticipated me exactly right it
was extremely unnerving I felt as if you
know my autonomy was really seriously
abridged and it was back to my rock
paper and scissors you want it you want
it you want to act randomly rap papers
is a pretty good model of the same thing
right but how do you do that well you
got to make something happen in your
brain that you yourself don't have any
access to so that you don't have a poker
face and then boom you do one
so in fact ideally if you know if if pan
glassy and god were to design you as a
free agent to play rock paper and
scissors the soon effects would show up
in your brain because you'd want him to
show up you wouldn't want to be able to
see the effects churning away in your
brain eight or ten seconds in advance
that was going to determine your choice
because then you'd give it away with
your poker face so what subjects you're
doing in those experiments
is doing something they have no idea
what they're doing
they're sitting there going I don't know
and somehow or other they managed to
provoke something to happen in their
brain which over a course of actually
sends the experimental situation puts
them in a condition where they something
happens in their brain which they can't
report and which is somewhat predictive
there's some real problems with some of
the predictiveness first of all notice
that they're not actually predicted
their predictive in the scientific sense
but it takes you know hours of
computation to to get the predictions
out i used to say as a sort of joke the
big moral of the soon experiment is
don't play rock-paper-scissors for money
with soon with your head in an fMRI
machine but in fact go right ahead
because it's gonna take him an hour or
two to analyze the data
so you that's not I mean done you I mean
presumably you're you would disagree
with Stephen and that at the point he
made his decision the camera you would
say that decision was already
predictable from first principles before
he actually was consciously aware of
making having made this well well I
think there's a conditional prediction
that I'm sure you could have made and
you probably you could have gotten rich
betting on it mainly that he would put
all the factors that matter to him in
the hopper and he would say yeah I'm
gonna go but of course if he listens to
the radio ten minutes before he decides
and he hears about some crucial thing
happening then he isn't gonna go so all
bets are off so when it he actually
decide he decided when he decided and
even though look suppose that there were
political scientists who could study
Congress and two weeks in advance they
could predict how Congress was going to
vote on a bill and suppose they were
accurate
they are no when when did Congress
decide when they voted is real you know
they have decided when they voted
you